[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the family of a bystander killed by
police during a high speed chase
say they plan to sue we've seen some
videos
the family has not had many questions
answered the victim
the uncle of the young woman who filmed
george floyd's murder the department
minneapolis police and britney spears
eyes hiring a high-profile attorney
ahead of a hearing in her
conservatorship battle plus an inmate
claims he knows who really killed
college student
molly tibbetts and it's not the man
convicted of her murder
and mark redwine's former girlfriend
takes the stand in his defense
saying there's no way he murdered his 13
year old son
i don't believe he did it law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin
the family of a bystander killed by
police during a high-speed chase
now says they plan to sue the
minneapolis police department
the victim was the uncle to the young
woman who used her cell phone to film
the murder of george floyd
my brother got took away from us for no
reason at all the family lanell fraser
mourning his loss
fraser was killed last tuesday he was a
bystander in a minneapolis police chase
of a carjacking suspect
accused of multiple robberies i hope we
get justice
because my heart is broke my soul hurts
surveillance video from a gas station
shows cars
stopping at a traffic light then another
car is seen speeding through the
intersection
fraser's car enters the intersection
from the opposite direction
the police vehicle is seen following the
speeding car when the patrol car
collides with frasers he was supposed to
take precautions
he was supposed to slow down make sure
there was nobody else coming fraser was
the uncle of darnell fraser
the young woman who filmed the video of
george floyd's murder
seen around the world will there be a
lawsuit
you betcha their family has now retained
civil rights attorney ben crump
along with minneapolis civil rights
attorney jeff storms
minneapolis has to sit down and say what
kind of precedent are we going to set
for showing accountability to the black
community when we
recklessly drive at high rates of speed
in residential neighborhoods are we
going to be held accountable as a city
joining us today is the is the fraser
family lawyer jeff storms
jeff what is the family going through
right now especially darnell fraser
who's gone from witness to a family of a
victim
well brian the family's devastated and
unfortunately i've been with families in
this situation too many times
as of late uh you know you're living
your life you're going about things
normally and the next thing you know
your loved one is this victim of a
horrific
wholly unnecessary incident you know
here it's a little different because
we're not talking about
some of the more classic force examples
we're used to
here we're talking about a high speed
pursuit
but again mr frazier's death here
is all the you know all the same
senseless and unnecessary and uh was
avoidable
and so the family is obviously
devastated and
right now is really focused on preparing
to bury
mr frazier now jeff i know a little bit
about the nypd's rules and procedures
and i've looked at some of them
in minnesota or minneapolis sorry aren't
police supposed to stop chasing in
residential areas or where it may be
dangerous
to bystanders why not in this
neighborhood
well that's certainly brian with a trend
that's been across the country because
we've seen
how deadly these police chases can be
often resulting in little benefit to the
community
and so when we look at the community
where this was happening
once again we have a community of color
primarily in a residential neighborhood
primarily comprised of people of color
and you know usa today did a very
interesting study about five years ago
that showed that uh black americans
including innocent bystanders are three
times more likely
to be killed as a result of a high speed
police
chase uh when compared to other groups
interesting to see how those numbers
play out now jeff at a press conference
that we just showed moments ago
you said you were waiting for more facts
before filing a lawsuit
what facts are you waiting for and why
the wait
well you know brian part of it's mundane
and the other part of it is the need for
investigation
you know in order to bring a wrongful
death suit there are certain procedural
elements and
processes that we have to fulfill in
minnesota so that's part of it
the other aspect is there is a need to
investigate this case and to investigate
what makes for the strongest
type of case it's going to require
analyzing every single aspect of this
chase
which we don't have but i do think it's
important
you know you hear a lot about people
talk about how difficult
uh these types of cases can be to pursue
and i think it's important for the city
of minneapolis to know
that we're committed you know we've seen
evidence that we believe is sufficient
to bring a lawsuit
and we're committed to the fraser family
to bring the strongest lawsuit possible
because i don't think that you know
frankly personally i just can't watch
another innocent black man die
in minneapolis and not do anything about
it so we're going to
pursue this to the fullest extent of the
law thank you for the update jeff storms
we look forward to pursuing this case as
more evidence rolls out and you continue
to file motions and lawsuits in this
case and others
thank you turning now to other top legal
news britney spears is reportedly in
talks with a prominent attorney
she would like to represent her in her
conservatorship
the pop icon has asked the judge for
permission to hire her own attorney
the new york times was reporting she now
knows who she wants
matthew rosengart is a former federal
prosecutor turned defense attorney and
civil litigator
he's represented other celebrities in
the past including sean penn
and steven spielberg a hearing on the
matter is set for wednesday
rosengard is expected to attend
terry in talks to retain a high-profile
lawyer britney spears seems able to at
least handle some
legal matters right absolutely i mean if
matthew rosengard
is indeed hired she will have all the
help that she needs
he is definitely a powerful attorney
he's a former federal prosecutor he was
with the justice department and
highly regarded and you know i think
that he will help her he also
clerked for justice david suter prior to
but becoming a supreme court justice so
he knows the law and i think he'll be
able to help her
with her matters as far as this
conservatorship
is concerned and 13 years is certainly
long enough and if anyone can help her
in the conservative ship it is this
attorney
so i'm getting a feeling that you're you
believe that a little bit more of a
vocal britney spears and the expertise
of this new attorney
we might get some traction going forward
in this case right
exactly i mean we have some traction
already brian we see
that the former lawyer stepped down and
made way for this lawyer we saw that the
manager stepped down and we
saw that bessemer trust stepped down so
now we just have to get
her father to step down all right we'll
see how this plays out of course britney
spears at odds with her father jamie
spears in his conservatorship
new council being appointed as this
continues the battle for britney spears
13-year long conservatorship
still ahead on law and crime daily a
woman in prison for
one murder now facing charges for her
best friend's murder a decade ago
but first sentencing the murder of
mollie tibbetts but an inmate may be
called to testify
that could change everything what you
need to know next
welcome back days before an iowa farm
worker is scheduled to be sentenced
for the murder of a college student his
attorneys are requesting a new trial
saying they have new information about
other possible killers
angenette levy is here with the evidence
the defense believes the jury should
have heard
yeah brian christian bahina rivera's
attorneys say that this information
actually came to them from the
prosecution after they rested their case
an inmate is claiming that another
inmate confessed to him
about murdering mollie tibbetts
we the jury find the defendant christian
bahina rivera guilty of the crime of
murder in the first degree
after telling the jury that two masked
men forced him to drive to a cornfield
with mollie tibbetts
body in his trunk a jury found christian
bahina rivera guilty of killing the
college student
but now his attorneys say they have
newly discovered evidence that the jury
should have heard during the trial
that would have resulted in a different
verdict the motion for a new trial
states prosecutors learned of an inmate
who claimed another inmate relayed a
story about seeing mollie tibbetts bound
and gagged at a house owned by a sex
trafficker
the filing says inmate 2 admitted to
killing tibbetts
and carrying out the plans so the
hispanic man would be incriminated
tibbetts body was found in a cornfield a
little more than a month after she went
missing
christian beginner rivera led them to
tibbetts body which was covered in corn
stalks
bahina rivera's attorneys say the first
inmate's story is corroborated by a
second inmate
who claimed to be with someone who
pulled a pistol and put it to his or her
head and said
that mexican shouldn't be in jail for
killing molly tibbetts
because i raped her and killed her
behena rivera will be sentenced on
thursday he faces life in prison
an iowa prison inmate has actually been
ordered by the judge
at the request of the defense to appear
at a hearing
before that sentencing it's right before
that sentencing hearing is scheduled to
begin
it's not clear at this time whether it's
the inmate mentioned in the court
documents but this inmate is being
requested to
attend this hearing to say something so
we'll just have to wait and see and
certainly have it covered for you
brian thank you internet and wait and
see who we will for this exciting new
development
back with us is civil rights attorney
jeff storms and terry austin
terry this seems huge with an inmate
scheduled to appear the day of the
sentence could this turn the case on its
head
oh absolutely brian i think judge yates
the trial attorney he has a very
difficult decision to make here because
the evidence
at the actual trial seemed extremely
convincing if you remember the
prosecution
said one we have the video the video of
the car going back and forth sort of
following where tibbetts was going and
that was the defendant's car
we have blood in the defendant's car in
the trunk and we have
the guilty you know admission from the
defendant so if
in fact these jailhouse individuals
have information and it's not bahana
rivera that will turn the case
completely
on its head it's new evidence and the
judge may just have to
make a decision to have a new trial now
jeff
overturning a verdict is a long road to
home do you think corroborated jailhouse
statements such as these
could get the defense there well it's
certainly very challenging
ryan you know generally the the court's
going to look at how credible the
evidence is and is going to look at
whether or not the evidence is
sufficient enough to be exculpatory
but you know i think what seems to be in
their favor for my understanding is that
the prosecution was sitting on this
evidence
which implicates some of their brady
obligations so you know if the
prosecution was sitting on this evidence
for a significant period of time
it certainly gives the defense a much
stronger argument
uh to try to uh you know to seek a new
trial
there's a stronger argument potentially
a trial if they do get that and janette
how close
does this match up to the defendant's
testimony at trial though
you know there were some differences
brian you know christian bahina rivera
he
said at trial that two men came into his
trailer and forced him to drive around
and then something was placed in the
trunk by one of the men that doesn't
match up with this whole trap house
kind of idea of things so we're just
going to wait to have to hear we're
going to have to hear more about this
and i do want to mention that the
prosecution and the defense in this case
say that the prosecution actually handed
this information over as soon as they
learned of it it was right after the
defense
rested its case so we're just going to
have to wait to see what their
investigation reveals and what further
investigation
and the testimony of the inmate um
indicates when that happens on thursday
thursday's gonna be quite an exciting
day for this case when we get a
sentencing or a new trial
or was it testimony gonna spin it all
around we'll see and we'll
of course update you when that comes up
thank you all
coming up on law and crime daily the
latest in robert durst trial
in and outside of the courtroom plus
staffed 55 times
why it took prosecutors so long to
charge a woman in her best friend's
murder
more on pam hops charges after the break
[Music]
welcome back a major update to a story
many true crime fans
have been following pam hupp is finally
charged in the killing of her best
friend
betsy ferrier faria was stabbed 55 times
inside her home in december
2011. her husband russell ferrier was
tried and convicted of her murder
but was acquitted in a 2015 retrial
prosecutors now say hupp attacked
perrier
to stage the murder as a rage killing by
her husband
hup is currently serving a life sentence
for another murder prosecutors say they
will seek the death penalty
we have a person who not only
murdered her friend then mutilated the
body
staged the scene testified against an
innocent man
and then once he was acquitted went and
murdered someone
in saint charles county to prevent
herself from being considered as a
suspect and i i
if i can't pick a case that was more
depraved than that
this is it now to florida where
attorneys for the accused parkland
school shooter
don't want him to be called a killer in
front of the jury
nicholas cruz is facing 17 counts of
first-degree murder
for the massacre at a florida high
school in 2018. he's set to stand trial
this september and his defense is now
asking a judge
to not allow the event to be called a
slaughter shooting spree or massacre
they're also asking the judge to order
crews not to be referred to as a killer
murderer and the thing a term some of
the families of the victims use publicly
the defense is arguing these terms
violate his right to a fair trial
the defense is also asking the judge to
not allow cameras into the courtroom
for pre-trial hearings the judge is
expected to hear arguments on both
matters
at a hearing next month and in
california
another delay in the murder trial of
robert durst the real estate heir is
accused of murdering his best friend
susan berman in december 2000. testimony
is set to resume tuesday morning but the
judge sent the jury back to the room
the defendant was not brought in
attorneys for durst now say the 78 year
old's health is continuing to
deteriorate
be sure to tune in to law and crime
network for gavel to gamble coverage of
robert durst's trial
when we come back with the ex-girlfriend
of a colorado man accused of murdering
his own son
has to say about the time dylan redwine
disappeared
was a 13 year old killed by his father
mark redwine
welcome back would you testify on behalf
of your ex
a former girlfriend of a colorado father
on trial for the murder of his son
is doing just that 13-year-old dylan
redwine disappeared while on a
court-mandated trip
to his father's over thanksgiving
weekend in 2012.
his remains were found the following
year and in 2017
his father mark redwine was indicted for
second-degree murder
and child abuse but redwine maintains
his innocence and his former girlfriend
says that at the time
dylan went missing redwine loved and
cared for his son
we went back to the house the barbecue
and we played
football in the front yard three of us
and
had a lot of fun what kind of
dad was mark to dylan as you saw them
together
very attentive was there an occasion
when you were at mr redwine's house
and you observed dylan to have
a blood button a bed where he was
bleeding
the night that we barbecued at mark's
house
he had brought in the meat and dylan was
cutting the meat and cut the end of his
finger
so mark came in bought him a band-aid
and we went and sat down on the left
feet
and he had dropped he was dropped
dropping blood his lip to it
not a lot but he had a paper towel on it
like this
and then mark went in the bathroom which
is just right off the bedroom
bought a band-aid and came over and put
the band-aid on his
finger on cross-examination the
prosecutor asked red wine's former
girlfriend
why she hadn't mentioned this incident
of dylan bleeding before
including when she was on the dr phil
show to profess
red wine's innocence i talked to my mom
about it i've talked to my son about it
um so you knew it was important huh you
knew it was something important it was
relevant
i didn't i didn't know it was that
important i really didn't
okay i don't never brought it up to law
enforcement in the nine years
since this happened okay that's
incredible
ms alexander when the bleeding
happened in the living room was that
something that was specifically asked of
you or did you volunteer it
to when you were discussing these things
i volunteered
right the first person to bring up
anything related to blood who was that
me the jury is able to ask questions in
this trial
they wanted to know if she had ever been
to the area where the victim's remains
were
discovered just miles from the
defendant's home
we did we walked actually one day we
hiked up the road
through the campground and left the
mountain a little bit and then we
walked around and came back down and
approximately how much time did you
spend doing that
a couple hours uh any follow-up mr mayor
no honor thank you mr uh champagne yes
you walked north from mark's house to
the little campground right
yeah out the first door and to the left
you left and then you went up there's a
little campground there yes at the end
we walked
through the campground and then up the
trail and it's a trail right like
yeah traditional trails yeah
all right jeff we know all of your exes
would say amazing things about you
but for the rest of us guys this could
be some very powerful testimony right
well yeah and i did make a quick mental
list for ryan of which girlfriends i
might want to call for
a pinch uh but you know it certainly
could come across as powerful from what
we've heard and observed
it doesn't seem as if this particular
ex-girlfriend has anything to
gain from this however the the issue of
observing the blood and the bleeding
does come across
as convenient so while you know overall
it seems powerful
that someone in this individual's past
particularly someone who he was in a
relationship with that ended
you know might give us some positivity
there are some there's certainly
some reason to look at this with a
little bit of skepticism
a little bit of skepticism makes sense
since it's ex
i don't know terry the end of the day is
what red wine's ex saying
helping to raise any reasonable doubt i
think it is raising
some doubt i mean it's the first real
character witness so to speak by the
defense
and i think it's showing him in a
different light i think it's showing him
as she said he was very attentive
that he made sure dylan wore his helmet
he actually
called dylan dillyboy but
all of that isn't going to make that big
a difference i don't think because
the evidence is overwhelming against red
wine
we know for a fact that there's that
blood that's in the house
and dylan was in the house in
the custody of his father the last time
anyone saw him so
i don't think no matter what she
testifies it's going to make a
difference
all right let's see how the continued
trial of colorado against mark redwine
continues thank you everyone for joining
us and thank you for joining us here at
law on crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you